social media social media social media
do you know how many social media users
are there in the world 4.8 million and
still counting from the purpose of
entertainment to spreading awareness
from learning to taking business to
Great Heights social media have proven
to be an all-in-one solution talking
about social media and the business
World social media has revolutionized
business providing a platform for Direct
Customer interaction targeted marketing
and valuable insights it allows business
to build trust promote their brand and
adapt to Industry Trends embracing
social media is essential for success in
the digital age with the rise of social
media in this digital age lots of job
opportunities are arising in the market
the average salary of a social media
manager in India is 6 lakhs rupees per
year however in us it is estimated to be
$664,000 per year if you are an aspiring
social media maven then you are at the
right place introducing Purdue
postgraduate program in digital
marketing which will be your all over
companion with this program you will not
only ace in the social media but also in
keyword research search engine
optimization behavioral marketing
campaign management and much more with
this technical expertise you will also
gain complete Hands-On learning with the
tools like Google Keyword Planner CH GPT
Google ads Google analytics and there
are more than 30 tools in the list
reserve your seats first enroll now from
the link in the description box and pin
comment to stay updated with multiple
Technologies consider subscribing to
Simply learn and hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from us so
without any further delay let's begin by
understanding what does a social media
manager do what does a social media
manager do successful social media
management demands a strategic approach
encompassing various key tasks here are
the social media managers roles and
responsibilities it begins with crafting
and implementing a goal aligned social
media strategy followed by the creation
of engaging content for diverse
platforms wigant Community Management
involves monitoring and responding
promptly to social media interactions
while campaign management requires adep
planning and result analysis social
listening is crucial for extracting
valuable insights from Brand related
conversations analytics and Reporting
form the backbone tracking key
performance indicator and providing
strategic recommendations collaboration
with other departments ensures cohesive
messaging while crisis management skills
address negative situations promptly
staying informed about platform changes
is vital for adaptability and adance to
guidelines ensures legal compliance and
ethical standards this comprehensive yet
concise approach ensures effective
day-to-day operations and long-term
success in the ever evolving landscape
of social media
management so let's see skills required
by a social media manager social media
managers need platform expertise
knowledge of major social media
platforms and features content creation
and creativity strong writing and media
creation skills with Innovation thinking
and engaging content strategy and
analytics strategic thinking and
analytics proficiency is must required
community and engage engagement
effective communication and Community
Management is required next we have is
campaign execution planning and
executing social media campaigns are
must required for being a social media
manager next we have is adaptability a
social media manager must be flexible to
adapt to the platform changes and Trends
next we have is collaboration a social
media manager should be great at
Teamwork and collaboration with other
departments time management a social
media manager should be be great at
efficient task organization and erance
to schedules problem solving along with
that a social media manager should have
a quick resolution of issues and crisis
legal and ethical awareness last but not
the least a social media manager should
be great at understanding of legal and
ethical consideration also
responsiveness to customer inquiries and
feedbacks will be a cherry on cake so
let's begin by knowing how to become a
social media manager in 201 24 achieving
a role of social media manager in 2024
involves a strategic combination of
skills practical experience and ongoing
commitment to staying ahead of Industry
Trends here is a comprehensive guide to
help navigate your path into this
Dynamic field on number one we have
Educational Foundation while formal
education isn't always mandatory having
a degree in marketing Communication
business or any related field can
provide a valuable Foundation consider
pursuing courses or certification Focus
specifically on social media marketing
to augment your knowledge next we have
is skill development cultivate strong
writing skills to craft compelling and
impactful content develop a
comprehensive understanding of social
media platforms their functionalities
and Trends familiarize yourself with
social media analytics to effectively
measure and integrate performance basic
graphic design skills or Proficiency in
design tool can enhance your skill set
next is establishing online presence
build and maintain professional profiles
on platforms like LinkedIn Twitter and
Instagram to Showcase your expertise
actively participate in Industry
discussions share relevant content and
engage with your network moving ahead it
is important to gain practical
experience seek internships or
entry-level positions in marketing
public relations or social media to gain
practical experience volunteer to manage
social media accounts for organizations
or events creating a tangible portfolio
stay updated stay updated with latest
trends algorithms changes and emerging
platforms within the social media
landscape attend webinars conferences
and workshops to stay informed and ahead
in the industry developments next we
have is portfolio development compile a
portfolio showcasing your best work
including examples of content creation
Community engagement and successful
campaign management Network
strategically connect with Professionals
in the industry join relevant groups on
social media and actively participate in
events networking can open doors to job
opportunities and provide valuable
insights into the industry apply for
entry-level roles Target entry-level
positions such as social media
coordinator or assistant to gain
practical experience tailor your resume
and cover letter to highlight relevant
skills and experiences highlight
achievements emphasize tangible results
during interviews utilizing metrics to
quantify your impact such as increased
engagement follower growth or successful
campaign outcomes last but not the least
adaptability and continuous learning is
the must have skill Embrace adaptability
in the phase of Industry changes and
commit to ongoing learning maintain a
proactive stance towards the exploring
new tools and strateg IES to stay ahead
in the dynamic field of social media
management by following these steps you
will position yourself for a successful
career as a social media manager in 2024
equipped with a robust skill set and a
proactive approach to the professional
development I hope now you can start
your journey of being a social media
manager hit the like button if you find
this information informative share this
video And subscribe to Simply learn to
stay updated with the latest trends in
the industry till then then thanks for
watching staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simplylearn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
here